SALMAN KHAN: This is Sal here.
And I have Dr. David
Agus visiting the office.
And I want you to
introduce yourself
because you have kind
of an interesting life.
DAVID AGUS: Interesting
life is scary.
But I'm a professor of
medicine and engineering
at the University of
Southern California.
I treat cancer patients.
And I have a lab that looks
at new ways and technologies
to understand and treat cancer.
SALMAN KHAN: And that's what's
really interesting, the fact
that you're a professor of
both medicine and engineering.
And I guess that's
kind of what we're
going to touch on
a little bit here.
DAVID AGUS: Yeah.
SALMAN KHAN: And so this is
clearly a picture of eggs.
Why are we looking at eggs?
DAVID AGUS: Well, if
I gave you those eggs,
and I put them in your
office, and I say come back
in three weeks,
what would you have?
SALMAN KHAN: They would go bad.
I'm not putting them in
a fridge, I'm assuming.
I'm just--
DAVID AGUS: You'd
have a rotten egg.
Exactly.
But if I was clever and
I changed the temperature
in your office to 99.5%
degrees Fahrenheit
and I rotated those
eggs three times,
it has to be an odd number,
then at the end of three weeks,
I'd have a chicken.
SALMAN KHAN: So that's
what this other picture is.
You'd have this.
So you could either
have a rotten egg,
so this kind of crazy
mess, smelly thing, or you
have this cute,
adorable chicken.
DAVID AGUS: Although
they call babies, chicks.
SALMAN KHAN: Chicks, or chick.
Yes.
DAVID AGUS: Yes.
So a small change in
temperature and gravity
goes from chaos to order.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
Right.
DAVID AGUS: And so
we're going to talk
in a minute about cancer
and all the chaos that's
involved with it.
But realize that
that egg, I changed
the temperature and the gravity
and I went from chaos to order.
So while will it seem
incomprehensible and unable
to model cancer,
you're going to start
to see little changes
can have a major effects.
SALMAN KHAN: I see.
And this is what's a
little bit unintuitive.
So when think about
things like cancer,
I mean cancer is
not the only one,
we imagine that we just have
to kind of-- we have to kill it
or we just have to kind
of have to take it out.
But what are saying
is, hey, maybe there's
these subtle things, analogous
to rotating an egg three times
and getting the
temperature just right,
that can make it automatically
do different things.
DAVID AGUS: Exactly.
To me, cancer is a
verb, not a noun.
So you're "cancering"--
SALMAN KHAN: Cancering.
DAVID AGUS: --when
you have cancer.
It's not that you have
cancer, you're cancering.
And so my goal is to change
your state of your body
from a cancering to a healthing.
And so the first question is
how do you quantity the state?
How do we say who
and what you are?
And so technology is
giving us the opportunity
to do that as we go forward.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
I just want to get my head
around that because you never
hear that word "cancering."
I think you probably invented
that word, [INAUDIBLE],
or healthing.
Once again, when
I imagine cancer,
I think this is the way
most researchers think
about cancers, is
the set of cells
that have just gone berserk.
And you have to remove them or
kill them somehow or stop them
from spreading.
And what you're
saying is, no, there's
something going on systemically
in your body that is cancering.
It's allowing the
cancer to thrive.
DAVID AGUS: That's it.
So your first
definition of something
you have to cut out, a different
organism, that's bacteria.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
DAVID AGUS: That's an infection.
So if something from the
outside comes inside of you,
I give you the
right antibiotic, it
doesn't care if you're a man
or a woman, you're six feet
or you're three feet,
if that antibiotic
targets the bacteria,
it goes away.
The difference in cancer,
it's your own cells
that have gone a
little bit crazy.
And so we have to
change the interaction
of the body and
the cells in order
to make that patient better.
Very different than something
without, this is within.
SALMAN KHAN: I see.
In other words, I'm
just-- it's fascinating
because there's all sorts
of parallels in, I guess,
everyday life, depending
on what you believe.
But some people, if
there's crime in an area,
there's one point of view
that you need to police it.
You have to arrest
all the criminals.
But then, hey,
maybe the criminals
keep coming because there's
certain environmental factors.
Maybe there's just
a lot of poverty
and there's lack of education.
And so you're saying, hey,
let's look at the things
systemically, as
opposed to just--
DAVID AGUS: Hunting.
Put some lights in the area,
put some police driving by.
But all of a sudden, the
crime level goes down.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
Right.
It's not just about
arresting the criminals.
DAVID AGUS: Exactly.
SALMAN KHAN: It's about
preventing the crime.
DAVID AGUS: Let me tell you
about a clinical trial that
was done a couple years.
It's the coolest clinical trial.
And they took women
after optimal therapy
for breast cancer,
these they were
women who were
premenopausal, so really
aggressive breast cancer.
Half of them, after
treatment, got placebo.
And half of them got a
drug that builds bone.
SALMAN KHAN:
Interesting [INAUDIBLE].
Let me write this down.
So this is breast cancer.
So these are people--
DAVID AGUS: These are young
women with breast cancer.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
Right.
And half got a placebo, which
means just like a sugar pill.
DAVID AGUS: Sugar pill.
SALMAN KHAN: And then
you give that to patients
just to make them think that
they might-- because sometimes
the psychological
impact [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID AGUS: And
this was ethical.
And it's very important to talk
about whether it was ethical
or not.
It was ethical
because they already
got their treatment
for breast cancer.
And normally in those
women, we just wait.
And hopefully, they're cured.
And we see if it may recur.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
DAVID AGUS: So in those women,
we divided them into half.
And we gave this pill.
It was a placebo.
And half, we give a drug for
osteoporosis that builds bone.
SALMAN KHAN:
Osteoporosis, osteo--
DAVID AGUS: You say, why
are you wasting someone
with breast cancer's
time by giving them
a drug that targets bone.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
Right.
DAVID AGUS: The reason is breast
cancer metastasizes to bone.
SALMAN KHAN: And
it metastasizes, it
spreads to bone.
DAVID AGUS: It spreads to bone.
SALMAN KHAN: And that's when
cancer just goes, [INAUDIBLE].
DAVID AGUS: Right.
It goes to the bone.
It likes the bone.
So the argument, if I change
the soil, the seed won't grow.
Because remember, when
you have a garden,
you can give your
fertilizer or make that soil
so those tomato plants love it.
SALMAN KHAN: Right,
right, right.
DAVID AGUS: And so that's
what we're doing here.
We're making the bone different.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
And so once again,
the system thinking
is that before, if you have
these breast cancer cells that
are just growing, the view
is, hey, let's irradiate them.
Let's slice them out.
Let's get chemicals that
will be toxic to these cells
and kill them.
What you're saying is
cancer really starts
to become a real
negative once it spreads.
And what you're saying
is let's keep it
from spreading maybe where
it's the most common to
spread, which is in the bone.
So before the bone
drug, the cancer spread.
The cancer could kind
of take root in the bone
and then start spreading
and metastasizing.
This is what metastasis is.
DAVID AGUS: Um-huh.
SALMAN KHAN: And instead,
you're saying maybe
if you have this special
drugs, this osteoporosis drug,
it makes the bone that
much stronger and less
susceptible to
this type of thing.
And then that won't
be able to happen.
DAVID AGUS: Exactly.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
Right.
Fascinating.
DAVID AGUS: So at the
end of that trial,
the cancer recurrence
was reduced by 40%.
SALMAN KHAN: Wow.
DAVID AGUS: At the end of that
trial, new breast cancer, so
a separate breast
cancer-- because once
you have one breast cancer,
you can get another breast
cancer-- that was down by 35%,
SALMAN KHAN: Wow.
DAVID AGUS: So this notion
of changing the system--
because remember, this is
a drug that didn't even
touch the breast cancer--
had a dramatic effect
in the survival of
these young women.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
Right.
DAVID AGUS: So
again, it just makes
this a whole new way of
thinking about disease.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
Right.
So if we were putting
words on things, the way
that most people think
about disease right now,
you call it kind of a
reductionist, where they're
just going to focus on
one narrow part of it.
They're trying to focus on
this thing right over here.
And you're advocating for
kind of a more systemic way
of thinking about
it, where you think
about everything that
this might involve
or that might affect it.
DAVID AGUS: It's so wild is that
for the last several decades,
we're trying to focus on the
individual cell, and then
the individual gene, and
then the piece of the gene.
And we forgot to
take that step back
and look at the whole system.
And so remember, the
cancer is your normal cell
that's gone a little bit crazy.
So we have to model
that whole system
and figure out a way to control
it so the cancer won't like it.
SALMAN KHAN: Wow.
Fascinating.
And then we have pictures
of what some of these things
look like.
So what is this right over here?
DAVID AGUS: So this is a liver
that's taken out of a patient.
And the white spots
there are colon cancer
that's metathesizes,
again spread to the liver.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
So it's a cancer that
grew up in the colon.
And at some point, it was able
to spread and kind of liberate
itself and then attach
on to the liver.
And it's metastasized
to the liver.
And now, it's kind of growing
in this-- it looks, at least
from this picture, kind of
a cauliflower-like shape.
DAVID AGUS: Exactly.
Exactly.
And then if I showed this
to a surgeon, or someone who
normally operates
on livers, they
would know right away, hey, that
looks like colon cancer gone
to liver.
SALMAN KHAN: Right.
Right.
SALMAN KHAN: And if you look at
the next picture on the right,
that's colon cancer inside of a
lymph node under a microscope.
SALMAN KHAN: And
these are the lymph?
DAVID AGUS: Those are
the normal lymphs.
SALMAN KHAN: Lymphs.
And this right here
is the colon cancer?
DAVID AGUS: Exactly.
SALMAN KHAN: OK.
DAVID AGUS: And so
any pathologist would
look under a microscope and they
would make a diagnosis and say,
hey, this looks like colon
cancer gone to the lymph.
And in the bottom
is a different way
of looking at cancer,
which is a CAT scan.
So this is basically a
three-dimensional X-ray.
I took a slice
right in the middle
that person's body and those
translucent areas in the middle
there are colon
cancer metastasis.
SALMAN KHAN: This?
DAVID AGUS: Those
darker areas, yes.
SALMAN KHAN: OK.
DAVID AGUS: And so
what's amazing is--
SALMAN KHAN: That's
in their liver.
DAVID AGUS: Colon cancer looks
a certain way, in a lymph node,
in the liver, on a CAT scan.
And it always looks that way.
The body doesn't care what
the underlying genetics are
because the genetics are
dramatically different patient,
to patient, to patient.
But it always looks the same.
SALMAN KHAN: I see.
DAVID AGUS: So
somehow, evolution
is selecting out for phenotype,
which is what things look like,
not necessarily for genotype.
SALMAN KHAN: Which
is their actual--
the DNA that makes
up what they are.
DAVID AGUS: Exactly.
And so we're
focusing on genotype.
And genotype is very
important and it's
going to give us some
understanding over time.
But we have to also
take that step back
and look at the phenotype, and
look at what it looks like,
and try to change
those interactions.
Remember, if a patient
has early cancer,
we've learned a lot
in the last 10 years.
So if you have early
cancer, and I cure you
with surgery, the day
before surgery I can always
find cancer cells
in the blood,--
SALMAN KHAN: Wow.
DAVID AGUS: --even
though you were cured.
So the old days,
we thought, well,
you have to wait till it goes
out through our bloodstream
and gets out there.
That's wrong.
It's can it live outside
that original organ?
SALMAN KHAN: I see.
So there's someone who's
cured or they're not
cancering right now.
And there is actually
cancer in their blood.
But because they're
healthy now, or healthier,
or they're healhing, or I guess
however you want to call it,
that cancer isn't
able to take hold.
DAVID AGUS: And
those cells, they
can't live anywhere
but the colon.
SALMAN KHAN: Fascinating.
DAVID AGUS: So listen
to this experiment.
This is the wildest experiment.
They took a mouse.
And they took breast
cancer and they put it
in the left breast
and the right breast.
And they colored them
red and green, the cells.
They waited a day,
they went back,
and the cells were half
red, half green; half red,
half green.
Because we always
thought if cancer
is something in one
local spot, it really
is a disease that keep going
through the bloodstream.
And it likes those breasts.
That's why it keeps
going back there.
SALMAN KHAN: So interesting.
And when I always
think of metastases,
and I can never say
is the word, I always
imagine it, OK, that's
the cancer that's
finally gotten to
the lymph network.
It's finally gotten to the blood
vessels and now it's spreading
But you're saying that
there's actually often
cancer that has gotten
to the transportation
networks of the body.
But it has still
not metastasized
because it's not able
to take hold yet.
DAVID AGUS: Exactly.
SALMAN KHAN: That's fascinating.
And over time, we're going
to get the technology
to interrogate those cells
to say, hey, this one
can take hold here.
Therefore, I have to change
where it would take hold.
We're just at the beginning
of that technology that's
going to change everything.
SALMAN KHAN: And
the reason why we're
looking at these, the
fact that colon cancer
starts in the colon and this
is how it looks when it spreads
to different parts of the
body, what you're saying
is that we shouldn't maybe
be so fixated on just
the DNA of colon
cancer because it
can be very different from
one patient to the next.
But maybe on kind of
its macrobehavior,
it's phenotype, how it
looks, and how behaves.
And that way,
it'll give us clues
maybe on how we can change it.
DAVID AGUS: Exactly.
SALMAN KHAN: Fascinating.
Thanks a bunch.
This is very interesting.
DAVID AGUS: It's great.